making a scene outside parliament these
protesters say they want to disinfect
westminster after it emerged that a
conservative mp is being investigated
for rape
are the tories collapsing are you doing
anything to deal with your party's toxic
culture prime minister the prime
minister heading to the commons today
was unable to escape another scandal
from within his own ranks he told mps
it's not a widespread problem more a few
bad apples that are being dealt with a
sentiment echoed by his health minister
the vast majority of colleagues that i
work with men and women are really
hard-working mps who you know work very
long hours do huge amounts of work in
local constituencies stand up for them
here in westminster i think we do need
to be careful about the actions of one
or two individuals which happen in all
sorts of professions
this response has left labour's jess
phillips frustrated
it's a sort of terrible
shrug of giving up to say well it's just
you know it's not just the culture of
westminster this happens everywhere all
right then well you're the prime
minister
crack on with doing something about it
the arrest comes against a grim backdrop
of a long list of incidents including
inappropriate text messages watching
porn in the commons allegations of
sexual harassment and drug use and
criminal convictions for sexually
assaulting a teenager for sexual
assaults of two women and one civil
court finding of rape
westminster has long had a problem with
some in power using it to exploit others
often young impressionable members of
staff that was supposed to end in 2018
though with a new code of conduct and an
independent complaints process but as
allegations continue to emerge clearly
the system still isn't working
and that system has been under scrutiny
today with the mp in question asked by
his party to stay away from parliament
but still able to continue with aspects
of his role
i think they have a sense of being
different which is exaggerated
and isn't justified by what they do i
think the public know
when things are right or wrong and they
will see the wrong in this
and the public will soon get a say
because there are two by-elections
coming up both conservative mps both
forced to stand down the voters at
opposite ends of the country will have
what's been going on in westminster in
their sights
liz bates sky news